- How has Orphan Black changed my life.
How has Orphan Black not changed my life?
How has Orphan Black changed my life?
- It's changed my life in
so many different ways,
not only career wise, just
being able to walk into rooms
that I would never
normally get to walk into.
- I had no idea people
were killing off clones.
I had no idea people were making clones
and then killing them, and it's not right.
- It's taught me to dig
down and realize that
there's goodness in humanity
and something worth
fighting for in everybody.
- I just don't think that I
was an actor before the show.
Like, I know I was an actor.
Obviously I auditioned
and I'd worked before,
but I don't think that I
had fallen in love with
or been open about how
much I loved acting.
- Orphan Black was my first on camera job,
so I've been able to learn for five years
under the most amazing
mentor I could ever ask for
in Tatiana.
- We got to make a show for people
that didn't have as much
of a voice on television,
and that means everything to me.
- Well, I got loads of
free shoes on Friday,
so I'm sort of good for boots forever.
- I'm pretty sure that
clones are people too.
Like, I think technically they're humans,
so let's stop killing them.
- Orphan Black has changed my life
because it has shown me
the power of fiction.
- When you get people who are real geeks
and nerds for storytelling and character,
they actually can change people's lives.
- If it can push back
the sometimes oppressive
boundaries of the norm,
if it can make one person
feel better and prouder
and more open about their identity,
then I think fiction has
served its highest purpose.
- It's unbelievable that this thing
is now so important to
so many other people.
- The Clone Club has been like
life-changing in terms of
hearing stories from people
about how the show's affected them.
- The best supporters,
the most loyal fans,
and they keep growing and
growing and creating art.
And it's inspiring to see
their reaction to what we do.
- I never thought I would work on a show
where people testify that
the show changed their lives,
which is the most astounding
and rewarding thing about it.
- Giving them a voice, giving
them a conversation starter
for coming out to their parents.
- We're a show for outsiders
and for people that were marginalized
because of who they chose to love
or who they were attracted to
or what color they were,
and we took all of those
characters and outsiders
and we put them center stage
and gave them a venue to fight
and stand up for themselves.
And I'm very proud of that.
- How has Orphan Black changed my life?
I made lifelong friends.
Yeah.
- [Cast] Thank you Clone Club.